c'est au moca que s'est tenue le 3e
symposium du réseau interreligieux de
lyndiane océanie ce groupe de parole
accueil des délégations des conseils
religieux de madagascar maurice
seychelles ainsi que des représentants
des comores et de mayotte
ce symposium met en perspective la paix
en océan indien
toutes les religions son portage de paix
et si à la réunion qui dans l'aude il
est bien longtemps que les réunions
auxquelles les religions et bien vivre
vraiment ensemble que nous avons appris
à nous connaître nous estimer à vivre
dans le respect de la tolérance des gens
et les autres et bien ce vivre ensemble
l'a bien il faut que ce qu'il soit
partagé par l'ensemble de nos de nos
populations respectives mais aussi par
l'ensemble de l'indiana ciani deux jours
de débats et de présentations animées
par des chercheurs et des membres
religieux traiteront de la paix dans la
zone
la société réunionnaise se place comme
un modèle de cohésion sociale au travers
de sa multiplicité culturelle sommes un
territoire de migration nous sommes tous
des immigrés et à partir de là au fil
des vagues successives et bien à côté du
christianisme vous avez eu des autres
religions et à côté des églises et
temples mal par des mosquées des tanks
chinois qui sont venus s'installer
enrichir finalement la société
réunionnaise et ce qui est
extraordinaire de notre territoire et
dans les autres îles de l'océan indien
je pense à l'humoriste qui est très
semblable c'est que il y a un respect de
l'autre il y à une cohabitation de ces
différents métissage est finalement une
acceptation du dieu de l'autre le
conseil départemental des jeunes ainsi
que l' académie des dalons ont tenu à
participer à ce symposium
ils donnent leur propre vision de la
paix dans notre société
on a beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de
jeunes il râle dans la dalle sûrs et ne
veut pas c'est un message que les
solides et enfin contre nous te voilà on
a bon espoir que qu'on va y arriver
qu'on va réussir à vivre dans un monde
de pays en continuant dialoguer en
continuant d'échanger nos points de vue
et nos idées parce que c'est avec nos
divergences qu'on est plus fort
c'est en apportant un petit peu de
chacun pour n'arrivera qu'on arrivera à
faire un monde meilleur
après la paix dans la zone océan indien
le symposium interreligieux débattra
toute la journée de vendredi de
l'écologie et du développement durable
dans la zone